Tasha: 哈哈
Jake:露亚要不做个狗
Jake:啊我们一起来做狗吧
Jake:露亚 对露亚来指导一下
Lucia:可以啊我我这个马上快完工了
Jake:好 好嘞
Lucia:III believe so
Jake:我们来quarter一下
Lucia:不是但是他
Lucia:嗯我觉得还是有什么地方好像
Jake:好像不太准了
Lucia:对就这个
Lucia:这玩意他应该能但是其实也没事
Lucia:实在不行就不安里面
Lucia:结果把这冲墙
Jake:哎这个为什么
Lucia:然后他就是
Jake:不行不行我试试看
Lucia:你有强迫症啊哈
Jake:呃可以有一点
Lucia:OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake:这个首先这个是对上的对吧
Jake: First, this part fits, right?
Lucia:对这是对上的
Lucia: Yeah, it fits.
Lucia:因为呢一会我们把它方便装进去
Lucia: Because it'll be easier to assemble later.
Lucia:也不用拼那么死
Lucia: No need to over-tighten it.
Lucia:而且就是过几天可能还要把它拆开
Lucia: Plus, we might need to take it apart in a few days.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Jake:哦对哎这也依了半天哈哈哈
Jake: Oh right, yeah, this took a while, haha.
Jake:这个可能是放后面
Jake: This might go in the back.
Lucia:这玩意怎么又掉下来了
Lucia: Why does this keep falling off?
Lucia:就是
Lucia: Seriously.
Jake:哪个是放后面来着
Jake: Which part goes in the back again?
Lucia:呃这个上面有说明书
Lucia: Uh, there's a manual for this.
Lucia:好就是这个这框这样拼的
Lucia: Okay, so this frame is supposed to fit like this.
Lucia:然后所以我觉得吧
Lucia: So, I think...
Lucia:就是这个有有底下有这一条的
Lucia: This part goes on the bottom here.
Jake:对应该是挂准这样的
Jake: Yeah, it should hang like this.
Lucia:就是他好像是在这就是有一条的
Lucia: It seems like there's a piece that connects here.
Lucia:跟这个连着
Lucia: It connects to this part.
Lucia:你觉得呢
Lucia: What do you think?
Lucia:是这意思不
Lucia: Is that what you mean?
Jake:我试试
Jake: Let me try.
Lucia:没事没事我会把它修好了
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay. I'll fix it.
Lucia:对吧
Lucia: Right?
Lucia:所以理论上应该是就是不是你
Lucia: So theoretically, it shouldn't be you.
Lucia:你看一眼
Lucia: Take a look.
Jake:哈哈我知道我知道我知道
Jake: Haha, I know, I know, I know.
Jake:理论上是这么回事
Jake: Theoretically, that's how it is.
Lucia:对理论上他应该是这是跟这走的OK
Lucia: Right, theoretically, it should work with this, OK.
Lucia:然后
Lucia: And then...
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia:但是反正总之就是我安进去之后吧
Lucia: But anyway, after I put it in...
Lucia:他他他总是有哪不太对劲
Lucia: There's always something not quite right.
Lucia:就好像是长或者宽就对
Lucia: It's like the length or the width is off.
Lucia:然后这样把它推进去
Lucia: And then push it in like this.
Lucia:对哦
Lucia: Right.
Lucia:但是就是我刚才推它推不到里边
Lucia: But just now, I couldn't push it all the way in.
Lucia:它会就有一点在外边露着
Lucia: It would stick out a bit.
Lucia:就它没有办法完全融这个抽屉
Lucia: It can't fully blend with the drawer.
Lucia:融入不了柜子哦
Lucia: It can't fit into the cabinet.
Lucia:等会我先把底下这个修好啊
Lucia: Wait, let me fix the bottom first.
Lucia:好稍微按一下就好了
Lucia: Okay, just press it lightly.
Lucia:哈哈这被咱俩折腾完
Lucia: Haha, after we messed with it...
Lucia:这玩意还能用不
Lucia: Can this thing still be used?
Jake:要不就是空心的嘛对吧总有
Jake: Maybe it's hollow, right? There's always...
Jake:乞丐方案
Jake: A makeshift solution.
Jake:还有板吗
Jake: Are there any more boards?
Jake:还有板呢
Lucia:有吧
Lucia: There should be.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Lucia:但是接下来就是那三个配套的抽屉
Lucia: But next, we just need to fit the three matching drawers.
Lucia:其实就完事了
Lucia: Then it's done.
Lucia:这还挺好装的
Lucia: They're pretty easy to install.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Lucia:都是一些榫牟结构
Lucia: They all use mortise and tenon joints.
Lucia:差不多就这样但是再稍微轻点
Lucia: Almost there, but be a bit gentler.
Lucia:因为我后面装的不是很使劲
Lucia: I didn't use much force when I assembled it.
Lucia:我怕太用劲把压的那啥了对
Lucia: I was afraid if I used too much force, it would mess it up.
Lucia:你先按要不先按上面的
Lucia: Press the top one first.
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia:就总觉得有点有哪里不对
Lucia: I just feel like something's not right.
Jake:哎哎这个像这么回事
Jake: Hey, hey, this looks like it.
Jake:哎不像了
Jake: Oh, doesn't look like it anymore.
Lucia:哈哈哈又不像了
Lucia: Haha, now it doesn't look like it.
Jake:像应该还是像的
Jake: It should still look like it.
Jake:可能得是
Jake: Maybe it needs to be...
Jake:这个稍微是不是出来一点呀
Jake: Should this be a little bit out?
Lucia:是不是卡的呀
Lucia: Is it stuck?
Lucia:好像是这么回事吧
Lucia: Seems like that's it.
Lucia:挺好挺好挺好
Lucia: Pretty good, pretty good, pretty good.
Lucia:就这样就这样就这样嗯挺好
Lucia: Just like this, just like this, pretty good.
Jake:大成功大成功
Jake: Great success, great success.
Jake:每天都在成功
Jake: Every day is a success.
Lucia:每天都在成功对
Lucia: Every day is a success, yes.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: No big problem.
Lucia:这里就再把它再按一下就好了
Lucia: Just press it again right here, and it will be fine.
Lucia:因为这个东西他都插进去
Lucia: Because this thing, it plugs in.
Lucia:他没有螺丝
Lucia: It doesn't have screws.
Lucia:所以就是这个
Lucia: So this...
Lucia:这个地方如果就不能太使劲
Lucia: If you press too hard here...
Lucia:如果太使劲的话
Lucia: If you press too hard...
Lucia:他这个这个地方就会就会脱出来好
Lucia: This part will pop out.
Alice:外面在干嘛呢
Alice: What's happening outside?
Lucia:稍等一下
Lucia: Hold on a second.
Lucia:哎看看这是他就会出来
Lucia: Look, it will pop out.
Jake:好去吧
Jake: Okay, go ahead.
Alice:他们在干嘛
Alice: What are they doing?
Jake:他们在唱歌啊
Jake: They're singing.
Tasha: 压花 啊
Tasha: Printing flowers.
Lucia:啊嗯
Lucia: Oh, yes.
Lucia:外面可以卡拉OK吗
Lucia: Can they do karaoke outside?
Jake:对他们在唱歌啊
Jake: Yes, they're singing.
Jake:可以一会啊
Jake: Yes, go later.
Jake:后面对去吧
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake:哎这怎么对不上了
Jake: Why doesn't this fit?
Lucia:可以对上
Lucia: It can fit.
Jake:对上了对上了
Jake: It fits, it fits.
Lucia:就是要因为它都是一些塑料板
Lucia: Because these are all plastic panels.
Lucia:对然后把它插个大概进去就完事了
Lucia: Yes, just push it in a bit, and it's done.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright
Lucia:稍等一下啊
Lucia: Hold on a second
Lucia:这好像 这个没有
Lucia: This seems like... this doesn't have it
Lucia:这个就是理论上它要按紧
Lucia: So theoretically, you need to press it tightly
Jake:哦好行
Jake: Oh, okay
Lucia:然后稍等
Lucia: Then wait a bit
Lucia:我先把这个放哪去了
Lucia: I'll see where I put this first
Jake:理伦上要按紧咱就不按紧
Jake: If theoretically it needs to be pressed tightly, we won't press it tightly
露西板:对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia:因为这个摁紧环还有点难摁
Lucia: Because pressing this ring tightly is a bit difficult
Jake:好的咱就不按紧
Jake: Okay, we won't press it tightly then
Lucia:我不会把它当作游戏
Lucia: I wouldn't treat this as a game
Lucia:嗯 前面这个地方
Lucia: Hmm, this part here
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Lucia:对就就最下面上
Lucia: Yeah, the very bottom
Lucia:刚才有最下面拉垮
Lucia: The very bottom was a bit off just now
Lucia:好像有点
Lucia: Seems like a bit
Lucia:哪里卡着了似的
Lucia: Something is stuck
Lucia:因为这就是要把这个东西卡也
Lucia: Because we need to clip this thing
Lucia:卡到这一层
Lucia: Clip it to this layer
Lucia:他也是那个塑料壳那个地方OK
Lucia: It's also in that plastic shell, okay
Lucia:同理可证
Lucia: Therefore, it can be proved
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh my
Lucia:妈呀
Lucia: Oh my god
Jake:他不要被证明
Jake: It doesn't need to be proved
Jake:我们今晚
Jake: Tonight we
Jake:做什么呀
Jake: What are we making?
Tasha:米  呃 提拉米苏啊
Tasha: Mi... uh, Tiramisu
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Tasha:那尽快做
Tasha: Let's make it quickly
Tasha:他还要冷藏呢
Tasha: It still needs to be refrigerated
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Jake:现在就做
Jake: Let's make it now
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Lucia: 先这样吧啊后面两个没插进去
Lucia: Let's leave it like this for now, the last two didn't go in
Tasha:好还有肉松小贝
Tasha: Alright, and also meat floss cakes
Tasha:想吃哪一个
Tasha: Which one do you want to eat?
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Either is fine.
Lucia:两个天菜都很好吃
Lucia: Both dishes are really delicious.
Jake:应该是没有合警他歪就歪了是吧
Jake: It must be because we didn't tighten it properly, right?
Jake:合紧可能就好了
Jake: Maybe it will be fine if we tighten it.
Lucia:哦你说
Lucia: Oh, you mean...
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia:尴尬
Lucia: Awkward.
Jake:不太抗地震
Jake: Not very earthquake-resistant.
Tasha: 不上
Tasha: No.
Lucia:这这个这个这面就是墙
Lucia: This, this, this is the wall.
Tasha: 嗵嗵嗵
Tasha: Boom boom boom.
Jake: 提拉米苏要干什么
Jake: What do we need the tiramisu for?
Jake: 哎不对肉松小子要要干什么
Jake: Oh no, what do we need the meat floss cake for?
Tasha:：先把东西洗了嘛
Tasha: First, let's wash the stuff.
Tasha: 呃这些不是我的也可以不洗
Tasha: Uh, these aren't mine, so I don't have to wash them.
Tasha: 就是现在还用不到
Tasha: We don't need them right now anyway.
Jake: 柯欣在干啥
Jake: What's Kexin doing?
Jake: 露亚要不你俩做个小狗
Jake: Lucia, how about you two make a little dog?
Jake: 还是可以
Jake: That works too.
Lucia:可以 笔呢
Lucia: Sure, where's the pen?
Jake: 笔到了一波快递哎
Jake: The pen came in a delivery.
Jake: 咱看有没有用可以
Jake: Let's see if it's useful.
Lucia:哎哪一个是笔
Lucia: Hey, which one is the pen?
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 要什么笔啊
Tasha: What kind of pen?
Jake: 问问问问问
Jake: Ask, ask, ask, ask.
Jake: 问一问
Jake: Just ask.
Tasha: 没有我的
Tasha: I don't have mine.
Lucia: 同问蹲着弄好累
Lucia: Same question, squatting like this is tiring.
Jake: 嗯嗯嗯看一看
Jake: Hmm, hmm, hmm, let's take a look.
Lucia: 嗯我知道
Lucia: Hmm, I know.
Tasha: OK还没报呢但是
Tasha: OK, not reported yet, but...
Jake: 这咋没名字啊
Jake: Why is there no name on this?
Tasha: 芋头吧
Tasha: Maybe it's taro?
Tasha:我拆吧
Tasha: I'll open it.
Tasha: 哦不是那我就不敢拆了
Tasha: Oh, no, then I don't dare to open it.
Lucia: 没事里面还有一层
Lucia: It's okay, there's another layer inside.
Jake: 哇哦哎
Jake: Wow, hey.
Lucia: 这好像是我的
Lucia: This seems to be mine.
Jake: 好请
Jake: Alright, please.
Tasha:  这不是我
Tasha: That wasn't me.
Lucia: 吃瓜吃到自己头上的感觉
Lucia: Feels like I'm getting caught up in my own gossip.
Lucia: 好像是我的
Lucia: Seems like it's mine.
Lucia: 那个什么灯
Lucia: That light or something.
Tasha:甜糕在哪里呢
Tasha: Where's the sweet cake?
Tasha: 在外面好像
Tasha: Seems like it's outside.
Alice:今天背过一个灯嗯
Alice: I carried a light today, yeah.
Shure:  我们可以一起创作一些非常简单的
Shure: We can create something really simple together.
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure.
Shure:  随便弹一个
Shure: Just play something.
Shure:  就比如说掉的 1645
Shure: Like a 1645 progression.
Shure:  就这种
Shure: Something like this.
Lucia: 还挺重的
Lucia: It's quite heavy.
Jake: 好雨轩老师填词
Jake: Okay, Mr. Yuxuan, write some lyrics.
Shure:  啥玩意现在就拿着你的论文开始唱出来
Shure: What, just start singing your paper now?
Shure:  然后开始一个那个唱
Shure: And then start singing it.
Katrina:  草履虫变异
Katrina: Paramecium mutation.
Shure:  我觉得草
Shure: I think grass...
Katrina:  别说我以前还干过挺蠢的事追星的时候干过
Katrina: Don't say that, I used to do silly things when I was a fan.
Katrina:  帮人家站填词
Katrina: I helped write lyrics for them.
Katrina:  然后我就决定换一个小夜灯
Katrina: And then I decided to change a night light.
Katrina: 但是那是有原来的词
Katrina: But those were the original lyrics.
Katrina:  然后你在去押韵
Katrina: And then you rhyme them.
Shure:  我们就叫草履虫变异来吧
Shure: Let's call it Paramecium Mutation, come on.
Lucia: 里这是那个游戏的场景
Lucia: This is a game scene.
Lucia: 这个游戏叫纪念碑谷
Lucia: This game is called Monument Valley.
Lucia: 我觉得你应该 听说过就是
Lucia: I think you've heard of it.
Lucia: 啊就是大概咱上高中或者刚大学那会它很火
Lucia: It was really popular when we were in high school or just starting college.
Lucia: 有是有些重比我想像的要重一些讨厌
Lucia: It's heavier than I thought, it's a bit annoying.
Jake: 哦哟好重呀
Jake: Oh wow, it's so heavy.
Lucia: 对 我以为它是塑料的结果它是石膏的
Lucia: Yeah, I thought it was plastic but it's actually plaster.
Jake: 行那我继续洗碗
Jake: Alright, I'll keep washing dishes.
Lucia: 嗯 怎么会呢
Lucia: Hmm, how could it be?
Jake: 这是丢大号
Jake: This is a big throw.
Jake: 还有个蛋呢
Jake: There's still an egg.
Shure:  然后还有什么
Shure: Then what else?
Jake: 虽然有蚂蚁但是蚂蚁不吃东西
Jake: Even though there are ants, they don't eat.
Shure:  哈哈哒哒哒
Shure: Haha, da da da.
Jake: 有点奇怪
Jake: It's a bit strange.
Jake: 呵它一般在实物上面可是它不去吃
Jake: Haha, it usually doesn't go for food even if it's on it.
Lucia: 嗯 它是塑料的多好
Lucia: Hmm, it's plastic, which is great.
Lucia: 呃暂时还不能
Lucia: Uh, not for now.
Lucia: 因为还要放东西
Lucia: Because we still need to put things in.
Lucia: 你是说做狗吗
Lucia: Are you talking about making a dog?
Lucia: 其实只要那个纸够平整就可以了
Lucia: Actually, as long as the paper is flat enough, it's fine.
Lucia: 没事反正做了也是摆在外面
Lucia: It's okay, even if we make it, it will just be displayed outside.
Tasha: 可以先洗一下这个锅吗
Tasha: Can we wash this pot first?
Katrina:  看他他说哎你说换手机他就换
Katrina: Look at him, he said, "Hey, you mentioned changing phones, and he did."
Tasha: 要不我帮你一起洗吧
Tasha: How about I help you wash it?
Jake:哪个
Jake: Which one?
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 外面有啊
Tasha: There's some outside.
Tasha: 这里也有
Tasha: And here too.
Alice:还有一个
Alice: There's another one.
Tasha: 放外面吧 这里面有油
Tasha: Put it outside. There's oil in here.
Tasha: 不知道这个锅为什么变这么黑
Tasha: I don't know why this pot turned so black.
Tasha: 钢丝球能刷掉吗哈哈哈
Tasha: Can a steel wool scrub it off? Haha.
Jake:昨天好像刷过
Jake: I think we scrubbed it yesterday.
Jake:还是前天也刷过
Jake: Or maybe the day before, we scrubbed it too.
Jake:我都刷过好几遍了
Jake: I've scrubbed it several times already.
Tasha: 好咯 算了
Tasha: Alright, never mind.
Tasha: 边边呢
Tasha: What about the edges?
Lucia: 这样比较好看
Lucia: It looks better this way.
Lucia: 对就它
Lucia: Yes, just like that.
Lucia: 然后打打开就是这样的
Lucia: Then open it like this.
Lucia: 增加一些光影效果
Lucia: Add some light and shadow effects.
Tasha: 算了杨老板不洗了哎好吧洗吧
Tasha: Never mind, Jake, don't wash it. Oh, alright, wash it.
Jake: 呵呵牛逼不
Jake: Haha, isn't it cool?
Tasha: 厉害
Tasha: Impressive.
Alice: 有没有铅笔
Alice: Do you have a pencil?
Jake: 没有铅笔可以买
Jake: No pencil, but we can buy one.
Jake: 美团外卖可以买
Jake: We can get it on Meituan delivery.
Jake: 你要买吗
Jake: Do you want to buy it?
Jake: 我可能还要有点别的东西买
Jake: I might have some other stuff to buy too.
Alice:不用啦我等铅笔来了我在画
Alice: No, it's fine. I'll wait until the pencil arrives to draw.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我不打电话关机干啥呀
Lucia: Why would I turn off my phone if I'm not making a call?
Jake: 我尽力了我放弃了
Jake: I tried my best. I give up.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 还行吧
Jake: It's alright.
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Let's leave it like this.
Jake: 有些变化
Jake: There's some change.
Tasha: 变化很大
Tasha: A big change.
Tasha: 我来洗碗吧
Tasha: I'll wash the dishes.
Tasha: 你把那个搅一下
Tasha: You stir that.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 给你
Tasha: Here you go.
Tasha: 我来交交班
Tasha: I'll take over now.
Tasha:你把手洗一下
Tasha: Wash your hands.
Jake: 我去厕所洗
Jake: I'll wash them in the bathroom.
Jake: 我要干嘛
Jake: What do I do?
Tasha: 你就在这洗就行了
Tasha: Just wash them here.
Jake: 我要干嘛
Jake: What do I do?
Jake: 搅和是吧
Jake: Stir it, right?
Jake: 这我会
Jake: I can do this.
Lucia: 咱们有胶带吧
Lucia: Do we have duct tape?
Jake: 有胶带多的很
Jake: We have plenty of duct tape.
Lucia: 我好像今天还看到了一个
Lucia: I think I saw one today.
Lucia: 虽然它不是透明的
Lucia: It's not transparent though.
Lucia: 但是也勉强可以用
Lucia: But it can still be used.
Lucia: 是在哪来着呢
Lucia: Where was it again?
Lucia: 记得这应该
Lucia: I remember it should be...
Jake: 胶带有黑胶带有双面胶
Jake: We have black tape and double-sided tape.
Lucia: 呃都可以
Lucia: Uh, either is fine.
Jake: 双面胶双面胶
Jake: Double-sided tape, double-sided tape.
Lucia: 是在哪啊
Lucia: Where is it?
Jake: 你在哪啊
Lucia: 我认认路线
Lucia: I'm figuring out the route.
Lucia:这对
Lucia: That's right.
Lucia: 只不过就是他
Lucia: It's just that he...
Jake: 这个是
Jake: This is...
Jake: 是贴是这些摄像头的也可以用
Jake: It's for sticking those cameras, it can be used.
Jake: 这个也是双面胶
Jake: This is also double-sided tape.
Jake: 我只有双面胶
Jake: I only have double-sided tape.
Jake: 嗯我不对我还有黑胶带
Jake: Hmm, no wait, I also have black tape.
Jake: 黑胶带在哪呢
Jake: Where's the black tape?
Lucia: 是吧其实美纹纸也可以勉强当胶带用
Lucia: Actually, masking tape can also be used as duct tape.
Lucia: 但他还没到
Lucia: But it hasn't arrived yet.
Lucia: 哎是这个吗
Lucia: Hey, is this it?
Lucia:我识别的多精准
Lucia: I identified it so accurately.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈是
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Jake: 是人均AI
Jake: It's like everyone is AI now.
Jake: 现在
Jake: Now,
Jake: 大家组建
Jake: everyone is forming teams.
Lucia: 请在下图中点击什么什么图标那种
Lucia: Like the "click on the icons in the image" thing.
Lucia: 哈哈就为了证明你不是机器人
Lucia: Haha, just to prove you're not a robot.
Jake:我用手
Jake: I use my hand.
Jake: 我用筷子搅和是吧
Jake: I use chopsticks to mix, right?
Tasha: 就是这里我拿了
Tasha: It's right here, I got it.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 我了草的做一个然后
Lucia: I'm going to make one then...
Shure:  来自远方的情在向你问好
Shure: Greetings from afar.
Jake: 又要吃饭了是吧
Jake: Time to eat again, huh?
Shure:  他们根本没搞你
Shure: They didn't even bother you.
Jake: 又要点外卖的是吧
Jake: Ordering takeout again, huh?
Jake: 晚上吃什么呢ok开始吧
Jake: What are we eating tonight? Okay, let's start.
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Anything's fine.
Jake: 我那我搜一下小狗
Jake: Let me search for puppies.
Jake: 晚上吃
Jake: For dinner...
Jake: 有没有什么
Jake: is there anything...
Jake: 我们还没吃到什么
Jake: we haven't tried yet...
Jake: 中国特色食物吗
Jake: any Chinese specialties?
Lucia: 中国特色食物
Lucia: Chinese specialties?
Lucia: 都可以其实你可以按着大的剪
Lucia: Actually, you can cut according to the big pieces first.
Lucia: 然后剪下来再继续修改
Lucia: Then trim it down and keep modifying.
Lucia: 老北京炸酱面
Lucia: Old Beijing Zhajiangmian.
Jake: 吃炸酱面
Jake: Zhajiangmian (noodles with soybean paste).
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 纸板太硬了
Alice: The cardboard is too hard.
Lucia: 呃瓦兰纸确实特别难剪
Lucia: Uh, cutting vellum paper is really tough.
Lucia: 哎最终竟然选了李先生牛肉面
Lucia: Oh wow, they ended up choosing Mr. Li's Beef Noodles.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: That's fine.
Jake: 这我也没吃过
Jake: I've never had that.
Jake: 这什么时候开的店
Jake: When did this place open?
Lucia: 好早以前了
Lucia: A long time ago.
Lucia: 有一段时间店很多
Lucia: There were many branches for a while.
Jake: 我搅和的
Jake: I'm mixing it.
Jake: 我我还得再搅和吗
Jake: Do I need to mix it again?
Tasha: 不用了
Tasha: No need.
Jake: 啊你刚刚画的是狗
Jake: Ah, did you just draw a dog?
Lucia: 对我打了个草稿
Lucia: Yes, I made a sketch.
Lucia: 我想把五官定一下位
Lucia: I wanted to position the features.
Lucia: 但是发现就是对
Lucia: But then I realized...
Jake: 像猫精灵
Jake: It looks like a cat elf.
Lucia: 就是我打算
Lucia: So I decided...
Lucia: 我打算换一种
Lucia: I decided to change it.
Lucia: 换一种狗
Lucia: Change it to another dog.
Lucia: 不是我照着这
Lucia: Actually, I was drawing a Samoyed.
Lucia: 我照着这个萨摩耶画的
Lucia: I was drawing this Samoyed.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 但是嗯
Lucia: But um...
Alice:我一看 啊
Alice: When I saw it, ah...
Jake: 一点好哈哈哈
Jake: A bit funny, hahaha.
Alice:画的挺狗
Alice: It looks pretty dog-like.
Jake: 没有挺像狗
Jake: No, it looks quite like a dog.
Jake: 挺像狗
Jake: Quite like a dog.
Lucia: 对那就这样
Lucia: Yes, so let's go with that.
Jake: 好嘞来请
Jake: Alright, please.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 点菜点菜
Jake: Order food, order food.
Jake: 百忙之中点俩菜
Jake: Order two dishes amidst the busyness.
Jake: 我要干什么呢
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: 嗯 不用干什么
Tasha: Uh, nothing much.
Tasha:包上就行
Tasha: Just wrap it up.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 这走这走
Lucia: This way, this way.
Lucia: 我就要个招牌牛肉面吧
Lucia: I'll have the signature beef noodles.
Lucia: 我好了
Lucia: I'm done.
Lucia: 您点了吗
Lucia: Have you ordered?
Jake: 我也是招牌牛肉面啊
Jake: I'll have the signature beef noodles too.
Jake: 有人不是招牌牛肉面吗
Jake: Is there anyone not having the signature beef noodles?
Lucia: 不知道哎
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 不知道啊
Jake: 吃什么呀
Jake: What are you eating?
Lucia: 哎那个薇薇的地毯上也是这个小狗
Lucia: Hey, there's the same little dog on Tasha's carpet.
Lucia: 好可爱好像是一个动画
Lucia: So cute, it looks like it's from a cartoon.
Lucia: 动画人物吧
Lucia: An animated character, right?
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 那我要这个
Tasha: Then I want this one.
Jake: 是哪一个
Jake: Which one is it?
Jake: 哪一个来着
Jake: Which one was it?
Jake: 有
Jake: Got it.